can we play the questions that were
presented to Bill Belichick of the press
conference yesterday and then the last
one will be our next guest Tom Curren
comcast sportsnet New England so Satan
if you'll give me the questions coach
any concerns about Tom Brady being on
the cover of Sports Illustrated
distraction bad luck or are you just not
superstitious about that sort of thing
focused on the studious girl I know you
always say the best team wins whoever
plays better on the field but having a
home field advantage and playing in
front of your home fan Thomas does that
help you oh no go as dells in Kansas
City that's good obviously this is a
game that comes with a little more pomp
and circumstance as a backdrop whose
helmets is a trophy their own oh yeah
each Tom Curren comcast sportsnet New
England how'd you feel about that
question their tongue [ __ ] good about it
setting up the pins wasn't you knocked
out yeah writing right out of journalism
school that's what you did right there
that's exactly looking for bill is this
stuff all over the top sighs education a
little bit no no it's terrific i love it
what do you expect when you go to a
press conference with you that I expect
that I mean honest to god I mean it's
you I at this point know that if I WOB
something up there like that that's the
response i'm going to get and that's
something I can work with because that's
the point I was trying to make this
stuff becomes a distraction to him oh
well let me play the other two and you
tell me what you thought of the
questions here see a real good here we
go coach any concerns about Tom Brady
being on the cover of Sports Illustrated
distraction bad luck or are you just not
superstitious about that sort of thing
focus on the Steelers what you think it
a question too yeah I mean what are we
doing there we sure what do you think is
going to happen do you think it's going
to happen when you mention a national
magazine that the darling quarterback is
on the cover of it's going to roll his
eyes and he's going to say he was a lot
less
hmm bill fiying then he could have been
in that instance all right next question
Jill I know you always say the best team
wins whoever plays better on the field
but having a home field advantage and
playing in front of your home fans how
much does that help you that was
diabolical don't go out no in Kansas
City okay he got a great answer how is
the quest was the answer worthy of the
question no no but I think you could see
Belichick see his gears turned can I
find some place the home-field advantage
doesn't help anybody at all oh yeah
dolls in Kansas City get their asses
whipped but if you ask them how that
worked out last year when they had to go
to Denver and that noise and deal with
that pass rush mean it didn't help him
that much so he knows what visiting
consistency involved in some of his
answers and if you probe long enough you
can find them but he's like one of the
Flies she's got the conch who would you
rather ask a question to in front of
your fellow reporters Brady or Belichick
that probably Brady I think he's a he's
a you know he's going to try and find a
way to answer the question in a
diplomatic way I got have had good
success with him over the years because
I've you know been covering them for a
while so he'll usually try and no start
talking about the Patriots and next
thing you know currents phone goes dark
what if the Patriots pulled in Antonio
Brown how do you think that would go
over yes he remember man was it Edelman
or Welker who did the little welders
things well occurred well rest ryan
right yeah well just being good little
foot soldiers that didn't go over well
at the home base yeah he made fun of Rex
Ryan like every every answer had to do
with a foot fetish with Rex Ryan and
then I but that was handled internally I
was surprised at how public the Steelers
made it with Antonio Brown Tom Curren
back of course it's coincidentally that
his phone goes dark after he's talking
about
Tom Brady hashtag Tommy what would
happen if a patriot old an Antonio Brown
here to him he would be he would be
taken behind the bar in some place and
that would be the last you saw of them
going around the corner you never saw
him again it wouldn't end well and i
just don't think i would even occur a
Patriots player to do that too because
while I know a number of people of Point
oone the Patriots put a blogger roll
video every week that locker room video
basically passes through the KGB in the
Politburo before it comes out everything
you scrubbed and then it's disseminated
to the general public there's not one
renegade cameraman running around doing
you know body cam stuff I also wanted to
ask you about the Patriots way much has
been made of that the last couple of
decades with you know that they're not
afraid to get rid of anybody at is there
a point where they they would do that to
Brady or they could be forced to do that
to Brady let's say in two years we start
to see him become an average quarterback
would would Bella check pull the poor
plug on him yeah I think he absolutely
would not and Brady has absolutely made
he's reconciled himself to that fact
it's not going to end any differently
for me than it does for anyone else he
hopes that his agreed-upon end of his
career meshes nicely with the Patriots
when they agree that they're all done
the party's over whether that means when
he's 43 or 45 which he's intimated both
ages to me but if not he's going to keep
playing and the Patriots will keep doing
what the Patriots do I know it will be a
difficult divorce and it's not going to
go pretty even though Brady already
feels as if you know I'm ready for this
if it happens because I thought I'd have
Malloy and vinit Aryan seem Warren all
the others knew but it'll be tough do
you think that Josh McDaniels didn't
take the job in champ just go because
he's waiting for the Patriots Jim no
that's not the case and he hasn't been
given any assurances that the Patriots
would give him that job it would be too
long a wait for him because I don't
think
bill belichick is prepared yet to stop
if I had to put my chips on a particular
number i would say 2019 that'll be a
nice clean number though Belichick would
have been here for 20 seasons at that
point Tom Brady's contracts up Rob
Gronkowski's contracts up we'll see what
happens between now and then still
actually kind of a ways away but I think
that'd be too long for McDaniels to wait
putting on hold the opportunity to to
run his own place ok are you going to be
working on your questions to ask for
Sunday's game are you going to work this
weekend i ad-libbed you know it's just I
get oh my god I starts flapping my gums
and that sometimes you end up again and
you end up getting into thick stuff
Danny I got to start doing that dumb you
it can I say this I asked him a question
about timeout usage and the intricacies
of it earlier this year on the press
conference conference well 971 words
later she finished talking about it so
he enjoyed that that's a lot of know
that's a lot of words that's a lot of
words Danny if the Patriots lose this
weekend dot dot dot it's really going to
be a situation where it's as surprising
as perhaps that 2010 loss when they were
the number one seed and lost to the jets
it's not unprecedented you have two
tremendous players in belen brown that
you can theorize that they could
conceivably lose but I just don't think
the Steelers are the wheat Pittsburgh
Steelers team right now they just happen
to be in the position they're in as easy
as the Patriots road has been to get to
where they are Stewart's just had to
step around a Miami Dolphins team that
wasn't that great and then a Kansas City
team that played like they were six and
ten well good luck this weekend time
we're all pulling for you and we look
forward to playing a question and answer
with you and Bella check on on Monday
terrific thank you Tom by Tom Curren
comcast sportsnet New England he's not
afraid he's not afraid
dan patrick show weekday morning on
audience
[Music]